General Anderson and Natalia sokolova's
New Alliance has led to the true sons
being embedded into the Black Tusk
they've been helping Sokolova grow her
Fleet of hovercrafts in DC
there are concerns that this could lead
to increased mortar strike activity
division agents have been tasked with
taking down a new team formed through
this new alliance they are heavily armed
and know exactly where to attack in
order to do the maximum amount of damage
the first Target is Charles Chuck's
Crawford ex-navy he is an engineer by
trade he has control issues possesses
sadistic Tendencies has very little
regard for the value of human life
[Music]
Charles chunks Crawford had a background
in the Navy as an ENT or Electronics
technician nuclear power before being
recruited by the Black Tusk
he was highly skilled at tending to
reactors on submarines and preferred
deep sea over the surface he was known
as chunks when he first entered the Navy
because of his severe seasickness he
discovered that he could handle
Subterranean life better than life on a
Surface ship and asked to be transferred
to the nukes
considered as the Navy's best and
brightest nukes are known for being a
bit eccentric with some struggling to
handle the stress and demands of the job
but chunks embraced this position and
saw himself as the ideal nuke
however beneath his seemingly harmless
nickname an impressive technical skills
looked a disturbing and unsettling
personality
chunks was known to have control issues
and an insatiable desire for power and
control over others
his sadistic Tendencies were evident and
as disregard for value of human life he
would often take pleasure in
manipulating and dominating his
subordinates treating them like mere
tools to be used for his own benefit in
his mind the ends always Justified the
means no matter how many lives were
sacrificed in the process
his Twisted Behavior made him a feared
and respected member of the Black Tusk
his superiors appreciated his unwavering
loyalty and willingness to carry out
orders without question
chunks may have been a master attending
to reactors but his true Talent Lena's
ability to manipulate and control those
around him
everything's a working order but morale
is low main complaint
the food we've got plenty of MREs but
all we got are MREs
the crew is getting enough to eat it's
not enjoyable you want me to find you a
chef that's excessive but if we can get
some fresh food it would go a long way
towards boosting morale you want salads
yes there are plenty of wild edibles by
the river or we could just take the
campus in time
for now if you want a salad go forage
one
how's morale great your team enjoying
foraging not exactly
I told you to leave the campus alone we
did I don't need you drawing unwanted
attention before we're ready we found a
small community North of the city any
agent no all civilians some kind of
prepper Homestead community
they were isolated and well hidden not
that well hidden we spotted three of
them fishing and tracked them back to
Camp with a drone occupy or Raid
occupy left a couple of guards to keep
their operation going
we can rely on weekly Harvest from the
farm for the troops in DC and they've
already put up a fair amount for winter
do you need replacements for the guards
not yet but we could use transpo if you
want to supply the other teams
is it true is what true what people are
saying about St Louis I have no idea
what you're talking about
it is there was an attack you're going
to have to be more specific
Rogue agents working together what would
the outcast be doing in St Louis
you tell me you're acting paranoid do we
need to worry about radiation poisoning
from St Louis from Outcast no are you
sure yes if you're really worried get a
geiger counter where am I supposed to
get one of those Department of interior
Parks and Recreation your prepper group
a spy museum the power plant pick your
poison
[Music]
on first lesson these comps and may not
seem very significant but the last one
in particular is actually referencing
events that played out in the division
recruited novel
this is confirming that the game is
playing out alongside the novels and
it's quite cool to see the Crossovers
here
to give some background Rowan was a
former division agent turned Rogue and
was once a part of the sale of agents
that the novel follows
Rowan's family had been killed following
the outbreak like so many others
but she was later believed that the true
Sons were responsible due to the events
that played out on Roosevelt Island
when in reality this was a lie told to
her by the cell leader
her family were sent into a quarantine
but it wasn't the jtf or the true sons
who killed them
after the outcasts took over and seized
control of the camp the division
launched a strike and her family was
caught in the crossfire and killed
the division killed a family of an agent
and that was hidden from her
she would go on to weaponize a sample of
the green poison and then release it
into the water supply of an encampment
of true Sons
the true Sons were decimated but not
before they had spread it to three
nearby civilian communities
hundreds of people died
but Rowan would then find out the truth
of what actually happened to her family
and she took the Betrayal hard
two division agents were dispatched to
bring her in for questioning
he killed both and then disappeared
erections drew the attention of the
outcasts they approved of her measures
and given that they are now leaderless
she obviously offered them something in
return for their help
the attack in Saint Louis happened while
the cell was in pursuit of Rowan who was
on her way to attack one of the shd
calls
there were explosions and the buildings
around them started to crumble and this
is where Isaac announced warning
radiation detected
the outcasts were using dirty bombs
now it makes sense that chunks are so
concerned about this being a former Navy
nuclear technician is more than well
aware of the dangers of radiation
I don't think the story has caught up
with what happened at the end of
recruited so I won't talk about that
anymore in this video however given
circle of his response to this there
could be more crossovers to come
regarding the outcasts and I'm going to
speculate more on this in another video
soon
the story of chunks demise began with a
tip received by the division agents
according to their Intel chunks was
hiding somewhere within the West Potomac
Park of Washington DC
the Agents set out to take down the
Black Tusk outposts one by one until
they found themselves at the Lincoln
Memorial
black task had fortified the area
heavily and it seemed like a daunting
task for the agents to get through but
they were determined to stop chunks and
slowly but surely they made their way
through the facility
despite facing numerous enemies
including heavily armed guards and
warhounds the Agents were Relentless in
their Pursuit
finally they came face to face with
their target
chunks appeared to be caught off guard
and didn't put up much resistance
the agent swiftly cleared out his
bodyguards and in no time chunks was
eliminated
after successfully eliminating chunks we
have obviously only scratched the
surface of a much larger problem the
Intel gathered during the mission
considered a dirty Bond threat linked to
the outcasts
as per usual the first target has raised
more questions than answers
while chunks is now gone I think that
we'll be hearing more from him in future
Intel given the potential direction we
could be heading regarding radiation and
dirty bombs
in the next video that I'm working on
now I plan to dive deeper into the
season 11 trailer and the various
elements that have been shown including
the mysterious Hunter drones and related
Intel that has been uncovered
I also want to talk about the castle
sediment and the potential significance
of the name that came up during the
chunks mission
anyway thank you very much for watching
and extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]